on the eve of the presidential debate
with just 36 days away
from what i believe by far is the most
consequential election in our lifetime
well the time for urgency and all hands
on deck is right now as i have said many
many times
in elections you need to take nothing
for granted you haven't registered to
vote
well guess what i have a special part on
my website hannity.com
information how do you register when
does early voting start in your state
who is running for your congressional
seat do you have a senate race this year
when does early voting start and when
does it stop and what about if you want
to vote absentee this year
all the information you could want
you're going to want to go to the polls
and
exercise this incredible god-given right
a lot
is literally hanging in the balance
if you care about our kids our grandkids
the future of this country
you must do your part every major
institutional force
in this country in the dc swamp in the
mob in the media
the 99.9 percent state-run newspapers
state-run
broadcast state-run cable are completely
invested
in defeating president trump as they
have been well
from the second he came down the
escalator with melania trump
the stakes for the future for our
children grandchildren have never been
higher
we in the end we will get the government
we deserve
joe's stated policies are the most
radical
out of the mainstream of any major
political party nominee
in the history of this country radical
socialism higher and higher taxes and
redistribution eliminating fossil fuels
amnesty for illegal immigrants free
health care for illegal immigrants we
become the united sanctuary states of
america
and by the way foreign policy
appeasement i guess the iranians are
hoping for joe to win because they might
get another 150 billion in other cash
uh in other currencies and have to do
nothing for it
this entire campaign joe biden and his
running mate have been hiding
from you we the american people joe
biden almost never takes
questions from the press when he does
the reporters are pre-selected by
members of his campaign
and today he officially retired to his
basement at a whopping
9 52 a.m which marks the 11th time
just in this month of september that the
biden campaign put a lid
on any more events before noon this is
not
normal they are clearly trying to hide
things from we the people
have you ever seen a presidential
candidate repeatedly
call it a day before 10 a.m day in and
day out week in
week out for months and now here we are
just weeks away
36 days to an important pivotal
presidential election
meanwhile his running mate senator
kamala harris made a rare public
appearance herself today
naturally she raced off stage before
taking any questions from the press
zero transparency from people running
for the highest office in the land
and their friends in the media mob all
they do is cover it all up
they are the great enablers the great
supporters
the largest contributors to democratic
radical socialism
okay thankfully tomorrow well we might
actually get a chance to hear from joe
on several important issues that he is
heretofore refused to address
for example joe do you support packing
the u.s supreme court as is being
threatened by members of your party
leaders in your party
uh what judges would you appoint to the
highest court in the land if there
should be a vacancy if you were
president
remember president trump well he
published a long list of prospect
prospective judges does biden support
getting rid of the electoral college
like other democrats
why did joe biden's running mate promote
a fund that bailed violent criminals and
rioters out of jail
why did kamala harris also praise
defunding the police in los
angeles why joe did you say police
become the enemy
and by the way why did you support
reallocating
just a different way of saying defunding
funds away from the police
why the silence joe as this nation
watched night after night after night
looting
arson assault vandalism even hijacking
and taking over
or burning to the ground police
precincts you know all that has happened
that has rocked this country to the core
all summer long
you didn't even mention it at your own
convention
in the eight years joe when you were
vice president there were 4 000
homicides in chicago alone that's
barack's hometown
20 000 shootings you did nothing and you
barely mentioned it
joe got biden going to support gun
confiscation efforts
that his guns are better bozo o'rourke
supports and so fond of
hell yeah we're coming for your a case
or kamala harris believes well
she could do it by executive fiat you
support that joe
will you continue to support your zero
experience
son hunter and his sketchy overseas
business deals
with the communist party of china now we
learned last week
shopping sprees courtesy of china
russian
oligarchs ukrainian oligarchs
wire transfers all back and forth now
it's all out there just
take a look joe do you support that are
you going to say that you didn't know
anything
you didn't leverage a billion dollars to
get a prosecutor and you can't crane
fired
and why your son admits on good morning
america
zero experience in oil gas energy
ukraine
why did they give him millions of
dollars i don't know maybe because
you were the vice president joe will you
forcibly place this country on another
coronavirus
lockdown and where do you stand on
mandatory mass because you flip and you
flop and flop and flip and flail
the american people deserve answers to
all of these questions
and here is what i believe this is my
opinion this is an opinion part of the
show
has been happening behind the scenes
this whole campaign this whole summer
well i believe that his campaign team
they are seeing what we all see
they see that joe biden is weak they see
that he is frail
they see that he is struggling
struggling cognitively his staff they
made a very conscious decision to hide
him
the corrupt media mob in this country
has allowed him and them
to get away with all of this so joe
biden
is probably spent pretty much hours
every day all summer long
with four or five points that he
memorizes on every
likely issue that's going to come up
during a debate and probably
one or two scripted attack lines against
donald trump
in between of course plenty of scheduled
hot cocoa
breaks and naps of course in other words
the democrats
the biden campaign felt it was too risky
to put them out on the campaign trail so
they put all their eggs in the debate
basket and we'll see for the first time
tomorrow
how well that strategy of studying all
summer long has worked out
tomorrow i suspect that all those months
preparations
it will be somewhat effective he or
survived the democratic primary debates
but his staff the democrats i can tell
you for a fact they are terrified about
these three debates
we know that joe will likely take on the
same tone and cadence and pitch
that he took out with his joint press
conference on fake news cnn with
anderson cooper
and by the way he should be able to
deliver his carefully worded script that
they've been practicing all summer
but even his staff knows how fragile he
is democrats are just terrified of
letting their own candidates speak off
the cuff
and frankly they should be and for
plenty of good reason over the weekend
joe couldn't even seem to get anything
straight
did you know that he was in the u.s
senate well for the first time 180 years
ago
just like what 200 million dead from
covert 19.
just like he forgot he opposed the
travel ban just
you know like we're endowed by the oh
the thing you know the the yo you know
the thing
god endowed by a creator god the creator
of everything
or mixing up super thursday or mixing up
the states that he thinks he's
in at any given moment or thinks that
he's running for the u.s senate
here's a quick reminder i've made it a
priority
my entire career to work closely with
you from the time i
got to the senate 180 years ago
you know as well as my tenure as vice
president
you know if i have the honor of becoming
your president i make this commitment to
you
you're going to have an access directly
to the the white house
and i'm going to be right there with you
180 years ago joe really actually
that was probably the closest he got to
an honest statement all weekend frankly
all campaign
joe's struggles didn't end there during
a very friendly interview on
msdnc the conspiracy network channel
well just watch as the host has to
painfully step
in and well lift them out of trouble and
help joe remember his own talking points
this is how corrupt the mob is take a
look for example the paycheck protection
act
you know one percent of the money's gone
out one percent
one percent of the uh the that's not the
paycheck the
the the um uh the uh the bill for a
small
for major infrastructure may seem lenny
one percent's gone
out and the paycheck protection pack
went out
and you know but i think it should be
focused on businesses under 50 employees
the you know oh you know oh
oh nobody's here to help me by the way
is that the guy you want representing
uh us on the world stage this country
you think president chief
putin think they're going to eat this
guy alive what do you think the muellers
in iran will be thinking about him if
he's president
wow you really think he's capable of
leading the free world
i don't tomorrow is theater for joe
in other words joe will be regurgitating
his memorized attack lines
his four to five points per topic and it
will reiterate them five different ways
to get through the two-minute answer or
the 90-second answer
but by the way he's had an entire summer
to practice who knows who's going to
show up tomorrow i don't even think he
knows
and according to joe you have to vote
for him because well of nazi germany and
fidel castro listen to this
vicious attack well um i'm not sure
anybody that hadn't already made up
their mind there for trump believes but
who knows
but but that's you know he's sort of
like goebbels you say the lie long
enough keep repeating repeat and repeat
it
it becomes common knowledge they think
you know
i i think people see very clearly the
difference between
me and donald trump trump is uh you know
is a trump is is is clearing protests in
front of the white house
that are peaceful you know with the
military this guy's more castro than
churchill
okay really joe biden comparing
president trump to
two of the world's most evil monsters
jill biden just informed his wife
the media mob that no one is allowed to
attack
joe for his gaffes i guess i missed the
memo
because we're just calling it like we
see it and showing you the truth so you
can decide take a look
your husband has been known um
to make the occasional gaffe uh oh you
can't even go there you can
after donald trump you cannot even say
the word
i can't even say the word no but are you
done it's gone the gaff issue is over
before
so over so over i've been in the senate
180 years it's over don't talk about it
of course well fake jake tapper was more
than happy to comply
with a delightful little laugh and a
smile hard-hitting
journalism at fake news cnn now real
journalists
might be seemingly more concerned with
joe's
worsening so-called gaffs his trouble
with numbers
bouts of anger his inability to remember
days of the week the state that he's in
the office that he's running for
and his extremely light campaign
schedule
and total complete blockout blackout of
the media
they won't answer hardly any questions
more troubles by the way troubling is
still
joe's trouble with the truth in the past
joe has lied about his grades in school
he lied about having three degrees from
college
lied about getting a full ride to law
school
lied about where he came in his class in
terms of graduating
he lied about getting arrested in
apartheid south africa while
on his way to visit nelson mandela lied
about marching in the civil rights
movement in the 1960s
but he did praise the former klansmen
that filibustered the civil rights act
and was against the voting rights act
that he did
and he did partner with that former
klansman why because he didn't
want integration of our public schools
because he didn't want his kids
going to schools that were racial
jungles his words
he recently lied about attending a
historically
black university delaware state another
whopper
take a look hbcus
i i got started out of an hbcu delaware
state now i don't want to hear anything
negative about delaware state here okay
they're my folks problem is delaware
state university
denied that joe was ever a student at
the historically black university
in reality instead of attending uh that
school joe got a start
well in the u.s senate working with the
segregationist to stop
integration of schools and bussing
according to joe didn't want the kids as
i said growing up in that racial jungle
joe biden has been in the swamp for
nearly 50 years where
guess what lying is just a way of life
oh did i forget his plagiarism
neil kinnick did i forget his plagiarism
of bobby kennedy
he'll do and say anything for a vote and
really when you think about it
he hasn't accomplished hardly anything
nothing that i can think of that has
benefited the american people in 47
years
as donald trump likes to say all talk
tomorrow you'll hear all talk
all promises new promises uh how did the
obamacare promises work out
and worst of all he's now controlled by
the radical base of his party and
they're bragging about controlling him
like aoc
if elected he will carry out their
bidding if successful his agenda will
rip this country apart
it'll destroy and negate the very
freedoms that we have enjoyed
for our entire history in 36 years you
get to determine
well what guess what the government will
ultimately deserve